President Trump says the mainstream
media had become what part of what he
calls the radical left Democrat party
the president's latest tweets come as he
fends off allegations of racism over his
criticism of a group of progressive
Democrat Congress woman tonight would
take a look at how the media are
covering this controversy all week long
here's Fox News media analyst and host
of Fox's media buzz Howard Kurtz
[Applause]
president Trump says he wasn't happy
that some in a North Carolina crowd
chanted that about Ilhan Omar the Somali
born congresswoman who he was
criticizing along with three other
freshmen Democrats the president
unloaded on the press today tweeting
it's amazing how the fake news media
became crazed over the chin send her
back but it's totally calm and accepting
of the most vile and disgusting
statements made by the three radical
left Congress women and that their
movement now includes the mainstream
media but even pro Trump commentators
like Piers Morgan denounced the chant as
shameful and racist while the president
said he started speaking right away he
actually paused during the chant for 13
seconds
Trump declined today to criticize the
rally goers these are incredible people
those are incredible Patriots he also
ripped the New York Times columnist who
accused him of racism saying Thomas the
chin Friedman a weak and pathetic sort
of guy really nasty to me in his average
IQ columnist but kissed my a in a recent
call phony Friedman says he's respectful
toward people he disagrees with and
Trump should try that the Washington
Post and other outlets are branding
Trump's tweets saying that congresswoman
should go back to where they came from
and fix things before returning as
racist for Democratic Congress woman of
color have just spoken publicly as a
group for the first time about the
racist tweets aimed at them by the
President of the United States President
Trump has sparked a storm of outrage
after a series of racist tweets
targeting members of Congress President
Trump today denying that his racist
tweets were racist Trump's tweets have
been widely panned as racist though he
denies it but if it's that obvious why
don't straight news reporters and
anchors avoid taking sides by showing
the full context and letting readers and
viewers decide Brett
right away thank you